imagine if you could stick out your
tongue and lick your belly button turns
out that would be an easy feat for a
frog if they actually had belly buttons
a frog's tongue is one third of its body
length and that's just a start this
miraculous body part that long tongue is
covered with thousands of mucus glands
which secretes some of the stickiest
spit on earth in fact when researchers
studied horned frog saliva in 2014 they
found these frogs could lift 1.4 times
their own body weight with their sticky
tarns that's like a human lifting a
refrigerator with their tongue because
of this frogs don't go whipping out
their tongues for fun but when they
finally do it can grab a meal straight
out of the air you see although frogs
can't fly many hunt some of the flutists
most agile winged animals like flies
moths and dragonflies they don't even
have to chase their meal they just sit
and wait it's even more impressive when
you consider that fly's experience time
more slowly than other animals each
second feels like four seconds to apply
so they have all the time in the world
to escape the predator just think about
the last time you tried swatting a fly
not so easy right well frogs have a
trick up their sleeve an ultra-fast
tongue their tongue is made of two
powerful muscle groups extender and a
retractor the extender fires the tongue
towards its prey and an astounding four
meters per second at the same time the
Frog flicks its jaws open which rotates
the tongue as it fires by speeding
bullet BAM
before you can blink it's all over
researchers found that frogs can snatch
their prey in under point zero seven
seconds five times faster than you can
blink but speed isn't a frog's only
weapon a frog's tongue is ten times
softer than ours
about as pliable as your brain and this
softness makes it super flexible so it
can wrap itself around its victim
slathering the fly with a super sticky
saliva
trapping it in place glue this fly is
going no way all that's left to do is
reel it in
the frogs retract your muscle Yanks on
the tongue which zooms backwards like a
bungee cord within fifteen one
hundredths of a second it disappears
back into the mouth to dislodge its
prize the Frog sucks its eyeballs back
into its head that pressure slides the
prey off its tongue ready to be
swallowed whole dope
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]